une femme sur neuf développera un cancer
du sein au cours de sa vie une sur 30 en
mourra même si les chiffres concernant
le cancer du sein sont encore alarmant
le taux de survie pour cette maladie
s'élève aujourd'hui à 88% mais pour
marie charlotte guy atteintes du cancer
du sein à 30 ans les dernières nouvelles
de son médecin n'était pas encourageante
il ya aucune mutation qui a été
identifié c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui il
est impossible de confirmer ou
d'éliminer la présence d'un syndrome
héréditaire peut-être qu'un nouveau
traitement viendra de ces neuf
chercheurs qui vont se partager quatre
millions et demi de dollars le docteur
claude perron travaille activement sur
un vaccin thérapeutique qui sera
administré à celles qui auront développé
un cancer nous c'est ce sur quoi nous
désirons âgées c'est à dire identifie
les molécules qui sont propres au cancer
du sein et stimuler une réponse
militaire forte contre ces molécules si
on a du succès avec un vaccin
thérapeutique
à plus long terme on pourrait envisager
un vaccin préventif pour les femmes qui
sont à très haut risque de développer un
cancer le docteur perd on prévoit des
progrès majeurs d'ici trois ans un autre
champ de recherche et celui des
métastases qui provoque la mortalité ce
chercheur de l'université mcgill
travaille sur un projet et on étudie
leur est programmé le changer leurs
normes génétique icône satisfait lui il
devient moins invasive donc finalement
six conti nous avions un virus c'est une
tumeur bénigne qu'il est là ep il n'aura
jamais la capacité de venir tous ces
chercheurs ont donc décidé d'unir leurs
efforts pour combattre le cancer du sein
qui demeure la deuxième cause de
mortalité chez les femmes ici catherine
kovacs radio canada montréal